oh hi on this episode of game life we
are going on a field trip hey pop quiz
hotshot what is the biggest money-making
video game so far in 2012 is Call of
Duty
no is it Madden not even close biggest
game of this year so far is Skylanders
Activision's combination of action
figures and video games have captivated
kids and have sold tons and tons of
copies of the game as well as figures we
visited the developer Toys for Bob here
in California and expect to define well
some sort of assembly line cranking out
the latest version Skylanders Giants
what we found were hackers and craftsmen
and a small team of guys who were in
love with the game that they're making
and they all work together in an
enchanted Tiki Room
I designed the characters for Skylanders
but I'm really just a tinkerer initially
we had a lot of different concept
artists and a lot of artists in general
just wanted to define and design
Skylanders because in the beginning of
the project no one knew what it looked
like and so we had a lot of people going
in different directions and for whatever
reason Paul and I just kind of melted
together and we just started you know
making the whole world so to design new
Skylander it always comes from the toy
first I always put myself in the
position of a kid you know looking at
toy shelves and going oh I really want
that you know and that's always first
regardless of the game so the beginning
stages of designing a character involves
mostly just me drawing for the most part
it comes from just dueling you know we
knew that there's these different
elements and sometimes I mean we knew
it's going to be a giant so it's
obviously a big guy that kind of thing
so that kind of helps define what this
thing is but I explore a lot of
different things it's many iterations of
drawings until we finally get tied down
to like okay color and then like the
really little details you know so it's
it's it's mostly just tons of tons of
doodles
the the second stage of the design
becomes we start mulling and super
high-res and have amazing modelers are
making it high-res at the same time we
start down rising it for the game
something that could be run in the game
and the animators start rigging it up so
we can pose the characters for the toy
so once we have a super high-res model
that's rigged and we can pose into some
ways I said there and pose it and trying
to figure out like it has a fit in the
package you know so we have a physical
constraint and it has it we have to be
able to fit multiple giant characters
especially on the portal at the same
time so they have some pose constraints
but for the most part we try out a bunch
of different things you know
three or four different poses we get it
3d printed out in color and then at that
point we can hold it in our hand and go
okay down that's the cool toy you know
so no matter how high-rez it is in 3d
and the computer it's a different
experience when you're actually holding
in your hand at the same time they also
glow as a toy they they glow and we also
have regular sites calendars we call
light color characters that also glow
when you put it on the portal and the
closer you get to pull the more glows
and there's no there's no it's magic it
really is just magic
there is no batteries involved it's
crazy I've been working on this for a
long time now it's just every time it's
a still magic for me when you put this
thing on recently when we started the
Skylanders project they needed a device
to interface the toys with the with the
game and I was like mom I think I can do
that you know and some new open-source
hardware stuff had started happening the
Arduino project was a big big influence
on us and one thing sort of rolled into
another and I started moving some of the
gear I'd collected at home a lot of this
some of the original stuff was actually
done in my basement of my house and we
moved more and more of the gear in here
including my old Heath cat training
training breadboard test kit and it's
sort of snowballed and so I've kind of
done listen this programming and more
and more electronics the Portal of Power
is a USB device that plugs through plugs
into the computer or the console
it's basically a rfid reader with a LED
for lighting we use the RFID tags and
the base of the toys and we read and
write to those tags so we can store
information about the toys progression
how much experience it's earned how much
money the toy has earned all stored on
the toy and we also store like the name
of the toy on the toy which seems like
an amazing thing to do so that when you
take your toy to your friend's place it
also reads there the same way
and it's it's really quite simple it was
so simple we did the first one using an
Arduino this is the this is the board
that plugs into an Arduino which sets
here this went inside a box that sat on
den goes Dean's desk while he scripted
the first versions of the of the game to
put the characters in and I have to say
the open-source hardware stuff really
helped us a lot it was tremendously
helpful to be able to do internet
research find find pieces that people
had done it's been a it's been a blast
fortunately we had the staff here to do
sculpting and the electronics and the
game design and our experience with
Dungeons and Dragons and fantasy
role-playing as well as our experience
making high quality kids games really
came together and allow us to make
Skylanders one of the things that we've
heard from parents particularly gamer
parents is that this is a game they
actually want their kids to play because
it's the kind of game they like to play
right you know you really love Diablo or
Skyrim or any other great fantasy
adventure game you love to see your kid
playing an age-appropriate fantasy
adventure game and we love fantasy or
old role players so we may ensure that
even though this is appropriate for kids
it's got that heart of adventure and
they serve heroic exploration arthur c
clarke said and I'm paraphrasing here
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
so a toys for Bob the way we make magic
is with the application of a
sufficiently advanced technology